Wahnsinn es ist wirklich möglich wie in einem science fiction nissan hat ein system vorgestellt das
Ermöglichen soll autos mit gedanken zu steuern und es ist nahezu serienreifen ranger
Technology heißt die neue technologie wie das funktionieren soll jetzt in klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
über das steuern eines
flugzeugs
Mit gedanken haben wir ja hier schon mal berichtet aber dass jetzt bei nissan ist ein ganz anderer schnack nochmal zum flugzeug
Statt mit einem steuerknüppel ist es mit einer haube möglich flugzeuge
Eben nur mit gedanken zu steuern ein steuerknüppel ist nicht mehr nötig allein die hirnströme steuern das flugzeug, im flugsimulator
Durch das direkte feedback also dadurch dass die piloten sofort sehen was ihre gedanken bewirken ist die steuerung bereits mit relativ
Großer präzision möglich mit hilfe von
Elektroenzephalografie elektroden werden die befehle gegeben normalerweise werden diese elektroden eingesetzt um in der forschung
Aktivitäten in bestimmten hirnregionen, zu messen oder auch in der medizin um störungen
im gehirn aufzuspüren aber dass ein gedanke damit entschlüsselt werden könnte
Das war bisher noch nicht möglich und jetzt scheint es zu gehen zumindest rechts und links können damit
Als befehle gemessen werden allerdings so beruhigen die forscher wirkliche gedanken können so nicht gelesen werden allerdings
Ist der algorithmus der an der technischen universität münchen entwickelt wurde so ausgefeilt dass
Er die beiden anweisungen rechts und links aus den hirnen signalen auslesen werden hier oben links
Im bild ist zu erkennen wie stark die befehle
Im gehirn gegeben werden und dann zur steuerung verwendet werden die
Genauigkeit ist zwar schon ziemlich beachtlich aber noch nicht so hoch wie bei einem steuerknüppel das liegt auch
Daran dass die rückkopplung der kräfte die an einem steuerknüppel anliegen fehlt es fehlt ein gegendruck wie an der steuerung
eines flugzeugs wie er da zu spüren ist jetzt hat nissan das verfahren aber deutlich präzisiert und
praxistauglich gemacht dabei hat der autohersteller eine
vorstufe gefunden die einfach aber genial ist die signale werden dabei nicht zum
Kompletten stollen benutzt sondern die technik lernt vom fahrer oder der fahrerin was vor einem ereignis. Im gehirn passiert dabei sehen die
elektroenzephalografie elektronen auf viel eleganter aus sie lesen dann tatsächlich
Gedanken und zwar nicht nur rechts und links sondern auch bremsen lenken gas geben und so weiter
Da das gehirn die befehle millisekunden vor der eigentlichen handlung gibt kann das fahrzeug jetzt auch auf diese befehle
millisekunden vorher reagiert
erschrecke ich mich also mit eine
notbremsung machen weil ein unfall droht weis das fahrzeug etwas früher bescheid und kann sich schon darauf vorbereiten genau so bei allen anderen
funktionen die fahrerin oder der fahrer sollen davon überhaupt nichts merken außer dass alles vielleicht einen hauch schneller gehen ich finde das ja
teilweise bei modernen autos mit ziemliche katastrophe
Die brauchen teilweise so eine gedenksekunde wenn man aufs gas tritt bis es dann
wirklich losgeht mit der neuen technologie soll das der vergangenheit angehören also dann haben wir wieder autos wie früher die sofort wirken wie
Losgegangen sind weiter gedacht hat dass aber ihre konsequenzen das hat sich ja schon mal ein flugzeug thema überlegt wenn wir wirklich in der lage
wären unsere umgebung
dann
Mit gedanken zu steuern weil dahin kann sich das eher entwickeln würde sich alles dramatisch verändern griffe schalter knöpfe alles würde verschwinden
Ja weil man es ja mit gedanken steuern kann und wenn dann noch die
anzeigen von temperaturen geschwindigkeiten und so weiter in eine brille oder in kontaktlinsen banner also dort eingespielt werden
dann
Stehen wir vor einer umfassenden verwandlung der wirklichkeit denn dann wird die realität erst durch die
zusätzliche virtuelle realität die
Argumente tea komplett ist wenn ich im auto die geschwindigkeit in einer brille oder in den kontaktlinsen
Eingespielt sie kann ich es mit meinen gedanken steuern und auch meine gedanken gehören dann
zu dieser realität sie werden unmittelbar wirklichkeit wenn ich dem auto befehle zum beispiel schneller zu fahren und das ist wirklich science fiction und
wirklich ein bisschen verrückt das verschmelzen von virtueller und realer
Realität wenn er kein video zu diesem thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir hier ein abo aufs auge und
vergesse nicht den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue videos informiert hier geht es weiter mit dem flugzeug video natürlich dafür draufklicken
gedanken steuern flugzeug ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran